Joker the upcoming standalone from
Warner Brothers in DC star and Joaquin
Phoenix promises to be a comic book film
unlike any other inspired heavily by the
works of Martin Scorsese and co-starring
his frequent collaborator Robert DeNiro
Joker presents the story of Arthur Fleck
a failed comedian with a troubled inner
life who becomes the Clown Prince of
Crime the most feared figure in Gotham
City's underworld more character study
than super-powered smash-up Joker is one
of the rare comic book films to receive
an R rating where the property as iconic
as its main character getting clearance
to push the film beyond the boundaries
of your average superhero fare was not
an easy task for writer and director
Todd Phillips talking with the Los
Angeles Times Phillips explained why he
decided to use the character to tell a
different kind of comic book story on
the big screen and what it took to get
the green light to pursue his gritty
r-rated vision Phillips explained that
the inspiration for the film came as he
was attending the premiere of his 2016
drama Deewar dogs in August of that year
taking it all in he couldn't help but be
distracted by a billboard for a
big-budget superhero movie which loomed
over the area he didn't say which one
but as The Times noted this was right
around the time Suicide Squad open which
happened to feature a supremely divisive
turned by Jared Leto as the Joker
Phillips may be known for comedies such
as The Hangover but he's also a Scorsese
disciple and he said he had been
disheartened by the last couple decades
lack of in-depth character studies for
which the master filmmaker was known
such as 1974's taxi driver and 1980s
Raging Bull both of which starred DeNiro
as he regarded the billboard the seed of
an idea was formed Phillips said I knew
that war dogs wasn't going to set the
world on fire and I was thinking what do
people really want to see the movies
that I grew up loving these character
studies from the 70s you couldn't get
those movies made in this climate I'm
staring up at this billboard and I said
to myself what if you did a movie in
that vein but made it about one of those
characters
[Music]
I'm an idea perhaps inspired by the
characters Suicide Squad depiction
Phillips became focused on the Joker and
as he discussed his idea with the film's
co-writer Scott silver the pair were
emboldened by the fact that the iconic
Batman nemesis had never received a
proper origin story in the comics which
was by design while various depictions
of the character including those in Tim
Burton's Batman and the TV series Gotham
had settled on the falling into a bath
of chemicals while escaping the Dark
Knight tact Phillips and silver decided
that it would be much more interesting
to offer up their own version of the
Joker's origin one barlas fanciful and
much more grounded in reality
Phillips said we wanted to look at
everything through as real and authentic
a lens as possible I don't believe that
in the real world if you fell into a vat
of acid you would turn whites and have a
smile and your hair would be green
instead Phillips went about reverse
engineering the story giving the Joker
an origin story that was slightly more
realistic it was an enjoyable process
according to the filmmaker it was one of
the most fun scripts to write because
you were only breaking rules in 2009
Phillips made The Hangover for Warner
Brothers and since that comparatively
low-budget comedy went on to gross an
improbable half billion dollars
worldwide the studio's executives were
inclined to hear him out on his vision
for Joker certain story elements of
which would require the film to carry an
on rating but there were seemingly a
million different objections to the idea
that had to be dealt with before
Phillips and his team were allowed to
proceed complicating matters was the
fact that a major regime change had
taken place at Warner Brothers in the
middle of the movies pre-production
Phillips recalled it was a year-long
process from when we finished the script
just to get the new people on board with
this vision because I pitched it to an
entirely different team than made it
there were emails about you realize we
sell Joker pajamas at Target there were
a zillion hurdles and you just had to
sort of navigate those one at a time
the process was difficult and
frustrating but Phillips said it was
worth it and that he's still kind of
surprised that he got away with it he
said at the time I would purse them in
my head every day but that I'd have to
put it in perspective and go there
pretty bold that they did this bold yes
but it's shaping up to be a pretty good
call joker is the most highly
anticipated film of the fall and
Phoenix's performances Jenner
strong Oscar buzz it's a radically
different approach to the DC Comics
properties than producers have been
pursuing with their shared universe and
may represent a new way forward for the
sometimes in battle brand the fact isn't
lost on Phillips midway through Joker's
production he suggested to Warner
Brothers executives that they create an
entirely new label for gritty character
studies such as his take on the Joker a
new banner called DC black according to
Phillips they weren't immediately on
board
he said the response was calm down with
a label how about you do one movie
despite the positive reactions Phillips
understands that his interpretation of
the Joker might not be every DC fans cup
of tea that's just fine with him because
he knows that his take on the Clown
Prince of Crime will in no way be the
definitive one and it certainly won't be
the final one he said this will not be
the last Joker movie ever made it might
be the last one what Keene and I do but
someone else is going to come along and
do another one just like with spider-man
so if you don't like this one don't
worry it'll get reinvented again they've
done four or five versions of the Joker
in the last 25 or 30 years so why not do
another one that's wildly different why
not indeed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]